sure but his and I don't want to give
away too many of the scenes but in your
film on the horizon the depth of you
know the motion that we see from him is
definitely not what you'd see just
quote-unquote pretty people doing I mean
there's a definite range and there's
some dark moments too
so where do you think you pull from some
of that because sometimes they think
well if somebody's pretty then they've
had it really good and they don't really
have that in them even though we all do
but yeah you know my upbringing plays
plays a large part in informing a lot of
the decisions I make of the regards to
script work and character work I think
we all have our struggles I think we've
all battled our demons and I'm no
exception and I think that as far as
Casey is concerned you know one of the
things that really drew me to him was
the way that he internalizes emotions to
such a degree and I always describe it
as impotent rage which is funny because
in in in one scene that may or may not
come to pass but uh yeah so from that
angle and then from that perspective
we've all experienced our traumas sure
that the drawing sure or not and then
and I'm not here to go into what they
are but I appreciate you sharing that
I'm wondering when you do go into a
scene that's like that are you going
back to certain things and you don't
have to share what they are but is that
where you can draw upon like when you
were in the desert together and some of
those scenes I know it was a small crew
well I mean substitution works and it
does work but up to a point there is a
point where where something there has to
be a substitution for substitution and
and in in this case it's making the
relationship real relationship between
Casey and ELISA and and in the
relationship between myself and the
actress who who played ELISA
I mean it's intense to just shoot a
story like the one that we did 12 hours
a day 14 hours a day kind of thing and
then detach herself from it afterwards
so I know that you know when we would
fight we would we would fight and I
would carry over
and you know and even even the next day
on set you know we'd have to kind of
have to keep bring us together we had to
resolve some things maybe from the night
before
yeah but uh I mean it was natural for
the relationship and and it was really
interesting for me that when we really
got going there wasn't a ton of acting
that needed to be done because the prep
work had set everything in motion his
directing isn't everything emotion and
and and at that point it was it was as
real it was as real as it could be and
it was as real as it got a long
comfortable sometimes which is which is
very cool because there's the thing when
you're shooting with we were three of
the whole true with three people me the
sound guy in an assistant so we were
such a tight family so of course
sometimes we just like bump head I mean
Tyler I think this was once that we kind
of bomb here and and it was my fault
because I'm like freaking immigrant and
I was using my word was totally wrong
and but other than that me and him was
just working perfectly but yeah sometime
on said he and the lead ELISA sometimes
we're bumping head and then the next
date was the big scene of just like now
it's time to hate each other and is the
big concentration so please now it's
time to crank it up and really go at it
so I think when it's time to reach for
those emotion it was you know it was
like it's right here
you